bruce aryans addressed the team after
the boat parade
and as bruce arians tends to do he
generated some memorable comments that
were
peppered with profanity here's a little
bit of bruce arians calling a shot
for 2021 i
i cannot i cannot take credit for any of
this
all right we have the best coaching
staff in the nfl
and we damn sure got the best players in
the nfl
all right and anybody that says running
back
bush all right that's kansas city's
[ __ ]
we're going for two all right we're
going for two and we ain't stopping
yeah uh hey everybody who wins one
thinks they're winning two
the only team that has won two since
free agency
really took root in the early 90s when
the cowboys were winning two in a row
yeah but that was still like
systematically it was still early they
were systematically dismantled once
people figured out how free agency
worked
the only team that's done it is the
buccaneers in 0304 your first two years
in the nfl
since then no one's done the paid in
almost 20 years yeah the patriots who
did i say
buccaneers but you know same quarter
here's what happened but here's what
happened
i spent like half of the season thinking
the buccaneers were the patriots
remember when the buccaneers were
getting ready to play the broncos and
i'm like what the hell they just played
them
oh it was the patriots yes and now it's
gone it's gone 180 right
now i'm calling the patriots the
buccaneers the uh well the broncos won
back-to-back
brady team yeah and not yeah well that's
right i forgot about the bronx yeah but
how could i forget about that stage of
people we're still figuring out free
agency the salary cap and all of that
but
well no no no no you got kyle's dad had
figured it out
figured it out yeah they were cheating
the salary cap but i'm not that's not
facetious they did
they lost like a third round pick and
more and they got fined hundreds of
thousands of dollars for cheating the
salary cap they did something with
elway's deal
and they they did they did i don't
remember i mean yeah yeah
if you ain't cheating you ain't trying
but yeah it's out there it's out trust
me the truth is out there 98.99
they finally caught up with them 2001
2002-ish
and uh they ultimately took at least a
third-round draft pick
for the salary cap violations that were
part of that team that they managed to
hold together all right anyway back to
the yeah the buccaneers
i i don't have any problem with aryans
being aryans
and you know hey they'll either do it or
they won't but it's not going to be easy
and as we've discussed it's going to
hinge in large part on what some of
these other teams do they're trying to
chase them in the nfc
yeah definitely and you know again you
said it's not it's
it's not easy bruce arians he knows that
he doesn't care
he you know he's going to coach the same
way no matter what so he's not really
worried about what other people think
about him and
you know who is this bulletin board
material and he's always got his team
juiced up
he gives his own team bulletin board
material so they play better
uh so you're right they're having fun i
got no issue with that
and the big thing is hey what other
teams do and more importantly
what they do i know that that'll be a
big big factor in this
yeah the salary cap what is it
eventually set at and then
we know they got some high-priced
big-time football players here that are
free agents and
i have a hard time thinking they can
keep them all i think they can keep the
majority of them but i would think one
or two of these high-priced guys do slip
away
you know i've been hearing 180 180 180
and there was a report over the weekend
i think shefty had it that 180 to 181 is
going to be the salary cap but jabari
young of cnbc had an item yesterday and
we wrote about it last night
at pft that the nfl is trying to get
the frameworks finalized of the next
wave of tv deals
before the start of the new league year
because they set the salary cap so
what you can do then and young says
these deals are going to be worth
collectively 100 billion dollars which
means it's probably going to be 8 10
years
of a package once you have that money
set in stone you can start shifting it
around a little bit
and maybe move some of the money to 2021
and smooth out more easily
the impact of the pandemic so that could
make that salary cap go even higher and
it could
eliminate the advantage that some teams
would have had
in an environment where players are
getting screwed and they're doing
one-year deals
and let's just go join some of these
quarterbacks who are trying to go
get a championship it's going to put
more even footing out there for the nfl
if the salary cap is higher yeah it
totally changes that aspect you're right
for that guy that we've talked about the
endama consu type guy who's yeah we're
going to really pay him 10 million
dollars from one year or eight million
you know what's going to happen there
yeah that that will that will affect it
but
that would be good news to the
buccaneers because they got a two
they got a few guys where you go they
got to pay big time money too
i mean there's no doubt i mean cr like
we talked about it a little yesterday
right mike i mean
you know the two guys that jump out to
me out of all the free agents you know
gronk okay
a b okay i think they're coming back we
talked about
sue it's just about finding the the
sweet spot
here's the the graphic to me the two
guys that are
and shaquille barrett okay that's
another one he can't leave
the you're he's he's too big of a part
of how you play football
so like i think that there are
guarantees to be back
now levante david and chris godwin are
the two i look at to just go
because again there's a lot of good
players on this football team they got
young talent
and levante david i think is going to be
able to command
10 12 13 million dollars a year on the
market maybe right around that range
chris godwin can be anywhere from 16 to
19 million dollars a year i would expect
too
so that's that's the two guys i got my
eye on going here into the free agency
and there's that extra dynamic of
breaking up the buccaneers disrupting
their effort to try to get
the team back together and win it in
jason light yesterday there
there was commentary about those two
people specifically chris goblin and
lavonte david let's hear from
coach and gm on those two players
the owners the glacier family they've
given us all the resources
to keep all of you guys together and to
keep you
next
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike evans with the microphone he
reportedly had told bruce aryans he'll
give up some of his money to keep other
guys around it's one thing to say
it's the other thing to do it yeah it's
another thing when you start seeing the
impact of that
on your gross and on your take-home pay
i that's a that's a big big thing to do
when you're it's one thing to
restructure and move money around you're
still going to get your same dollars
it's another thing to say
you know what i've earned this i deserve
this i've only got limited years where i
can make this kind of money but i'm
going to voluntarily give up some of it
in the chance that maybe we can do this
again and one more point on shaq barrett
18.99 million is what it would take to
tag him again because he was tagged
this past year that's going to be a
tough guy to keep around as well because
he's got a hell of a lot of leverage and
that's a big number
that you got to put on him to keep him
around for what would be one more year
right because then next year it's
quarterback money yeah or a 44
raise and i i think that you you make it
even harder to do a long-term deal in
2022. yeah no you're right about that he
would be a guy that i would think that
they're going to try to find a long-term
deal now i mean
it's two really awesome years uh you
know of his career
for this buccaneers franchise and really
he was good before that
you know with the denver broncos he was
just kind of stuck in a spot
where he didn't get a chance early on in
his career he was stuck behind von
miller and demarcus ware and those type
of guys
you know and then never really got a
chance to prove himself but damn he's a
good football player i would expect they
do
him first out of all these guys he's the
number one guy they figure out
you know chris godwin awesome player
love them
but they have a little leeway there they
got receivers so it's not like a
necessity where you're like oh man if
they don't have him they're really in
trouble now they got a lot of other good
guys
i i recognize how awesome he is and
levante davis the other one
that i just look at legend there in
tampa
been awesome but i i think he is going
to command a pretty dollar on the on the
open market and they do have devon white
and just you know just how far are they
willing to go to spend on these guys i
think is going to be the big question
that's the key when you have a devin
white and you look at the broader
linebacker position yeah how much money
can you justify
in that layer of the defense and
technically barrett's a linebacker
although he's a pass rusher but
you know between david and white can you
really
put that kind of money into lavonte
david when devin white
is just one seat one year away right
from being eligible for a big contract
of his own so that's going to be a
challenge and
sometimes with those guys that have been
such
a key part of the team for so long the
team thinks it can maybe
lowball them a little bit right and
maybe squeeze him a little
bit that way and then the question is
are you willing to uproot your life and
move
just to get more somewhere else and
remember the other thing the buccaneers
bring to the table is the no
state income tax dynamic which can be a
significant thing if you're thinking
about going to play for the chargers the
rams or the 49ers where it's there no
doubt
set in the highest bracket that's a
factor in this as well and that
you know it's amazing to me that the
florida teams the teams in the states
with no income tax haven't
made more hay in free agency because
that's a hell of an edge
yeah that's a hell of an advantage yeah
you're right
i will say there there is a knowledge of
it through the nfl player community
right i mean there is no but my point is
why aren't the teams in texas and
florida
better yeah they should be better you're
right they should
they have that built-in advantage all
things equal
you you go there instead of the state
that's got the state income tax
no i mean it's a valid point you're
right there is an advantage there uh
i would say really the the biggest thing
through my years i mean i feel like most
of the nfl
wants to make their way down to florida
for sure you know they all do because of
that the lifestyle the warm air
everything like that it's great to train
in all that so
florida's always had that advantage you
know
really um you know but but you bring up
an interesting point
but i don't think it doesn't matter as
much just because all is equal and these
teams only got so much money they can
spend on players so
you know there's there's nothing some of
these guys can do you know about no
matter how badly they want to go down
there
and the the other side of this beyond
the guys that they may be able to keep
and i agree with you chris goblin is
going to be a very very difficult right
for them to justify because of the fact
that they're deep at the position and
there could be some free agents out
there that would want to come take his
place there are going to be guys
that want to come to tampa bay whatever
the salary cap is if it's 175
180 220 there's going to be guys who
are when the music stops they're going
to realize big money isn't out there
so why not go play for the tampa bay
buccaneers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports